today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
hey guys i'm starting to think
maybe the supreme court was a good
enough reason to vote
for hillary clinton after all they've
done it donald trump's supreme court
nominee to replace ruth bader ginsburg
has been
confirmed by the senate and
sworn in at a very trashy event last
night at the white house amy coney
barrett is
in and it is over republicans during
barack obama's presidency
saying we don't confirm supreme court
justices in the last year of a
presidency
and with seven last night just shy
of a week or just beyond one week to go
before
a presidential election confirming and
swearing
in a supreme court justice and amy coney
barrett will now be on the court
to rule over any possible
election-related matters and there very
well may be some which we will be
talking about this week
so not coming as an acute surprise in
the sense that we determined weeks ago
there was no way for democrats to
prevent this from happening and indeed
they did not prevent this from happening
and she is now on the court
they won got to hand it to him mitch
mcconnell
gleeful on fox news last night and this
is how it works sadly they stopped
barack
obama's nominee merrick garland because
they controlled the senate
they stopped it with garbage arguments
which they immediately
threw into the trash and now under
donald trump
because they control the senate trump
has confirmed
three supreme court justices and we have
a
six to three majority uh against
the better judgment of doctors
everywhere the trump administration put
together a white house event
to swear in amy coney barrett last night
melania trump who still had coronavirus
symptoms
serious enough for her to miss attending
a trump rally
just days ago uh showing up with no mask
at this event right near a whole bunch
of people here is trump making no sense
whatsoever and they came
completely nonsensical run-on sentence
we are fulfilling
the duty that passes to each new
generation to sustain
the national traditions and virtues that
make possible
everything we have achieved before that
we will do tomorrow because of
our just unintelligible
and then eventually the swearing in
itself taking place
with clarence thomas happening naturally
without masks
or social distancing clarence thomas at
one point
whispering into the ear of amy coney
barrett in close proximity as donald
trump
looks on here is mitch mcconnell the
republican senate majority leader
straight up saying amy coney barrett
will be a political asset wait
but but but but i thought that these
justices
simply interpreted the law and applied
it to
no no no she's going to be a political
asset says mitch mcconnell voting for
biden
well if you recall we had a supreme
court fight a month before the election
in 2018 and we actually gained seats
i think this nominee will be a political
asset
for our candidates around the country
not a liability but an asset
that's a supreme court justice he's
talking about
as a political asset not an interpreter
of the law
not a mere conduit through which the
constitution
and case law flow and spit out like a
machine
some kind of decision no no they're not
even hiding it a political asset
and then here is lindsey graham who is
in a very tough race in south carolina
saying amy coney barrett will help us to
keep our seats we're in a fight for our
life
help me help all of us keep our seats
so we can do this four more years
lindsey graham.com
lindsey graham republican senator from
south carolina
in a really tough situation all of a
sudden against the democratic challenger
jamie harrison
says amy coney barrett might help him
to keep his seat they aren't even
pretending now we have to really
understand a lot of different things
here
there were leftists who missed the boat
in 2016.
okay they said it's not whoever
trump hillary it's all the same supreme
court
who cares it's not important well
we not we learned that that was the
wrong approach we now have
three lunatics on the supreme court
and you could say hillary clinton
wouldn't have put a real
progressive on the court uh but she
wasn't going to put on
religious nut ideologues and cuckoo for
coco puffs jurists
uh she wouldn't have done it okay we
would be in
we wouldn't be talking about is abortion
in danger
is gay marriage in danger is religious
liberty as it is
actually supposed to exist in danger
because remember
their their view of religious liberty is
the freedom of religion to impose my
religion on others that's not freedom of
religion
it is now all in danger it wouldn't be
had hillary clinton won well we now have
the 2020 election
um the 2020 election unfortunately is
now
going to be subject to this court
thanks to donald trump putting three
people on it
so we have a six to three majority for
the right
we all have to understand i mean listen
at no point am i going to
gaslight you just replacing trump with
biden doesn't fix the court it's too
late
okay we blew it we blew it this is the
court
until another justice leaves so now we
need to remove trump and vote biden
merely to have a chance to move the
court from six
three to five four and then if we get it
to five four to reverse it to a five
four
left majority or maybe expand the court
now we'll be talking more about court
expansion
i will tell you i am more in favor today
of expanding the court than i have ever
been
there are still political risks we're
going to talk about it i don't think joe
biden's going to do it
unless he really really is pushed
so this is a loss for us they want it we
have to deal with it as it is not as we
would like it to be
we have seven days until we can replace
trump with biden that will prevent trump
from putting anyone else on the court
for four years
so that is a win although it doesn't
resolve the situation
and then lastly the cherry on top mitch
mcconnell has
adjourned the senate until november 9th
putting in a supreme court justice in
direct contravention to the principles
he said apply during the last year of of
a presidential term
in 2016 and then immediately adjourning
the senate
meaning no coronavirus stimulus
even possible before the election
they won't even reconvene until november
9th
unbelievable this is the guy this is the
guy that's running the senate
we've got to end it guys it it must be
stopped
i have breaking news about authoritarian
repression of the media for you
the president donald trump said
yesterday it should be
illegal for the news media to cover and
report
on the coronavirus pandemic when there's
an election about to happen
now as you may know we have more than
230 000 deaths in the u.s
from coronavirus we have one of the
highest per capita case rates
in the world we have one of the highest
per capita death
rates in the world we have four percent
of the population
and 20 of the deaths we are potentially
heading into
the worst period for the u.s in history
from the standpoint of public health and
it is imperative
that every american understand what's
going on rising cases
rising deaths what the stakes are and
what we must do
and trump wants it to be illegal for
news media
to report on a pandemic during a
pandemic
because he's trying to hide it so he can
get himself another four years in the
oval office
because he has failed miserably in
dealing with the virus trump tweeting
quote
we have made tremendous progress with
the china virus
but the fake news refuses to talk about
it this close to the election
kovidkovidkovid is being used by them
in total coordination in order to change
our great early election
numbers should be an election
law violation
trump then complaining that cnn is
talking about covid
during one of his three rallies
yesterday take a look
getting tired you turn on cnn that's all
they cover
covet covert pandemic cove at covet cove
you know why they're trying to talk
everybody out of voting people aren't
buying it cnn you dumb bastards they're
not
that's all they talk about
how delusional is this is this evil
is it sociopathic is it merely
dictatorial
this is happening in the middle of the
united states hitting new single day
records
for cases over the weekend 81 000 cases
on friday
79 000 cases on saturday records
we're in covid hell in the united states
and trump is saying it should be illegal
for the news media to pick stories i
thought this guy was against regulation
i thought this guy was about
letting everybody do what they want to
do and
stopping oppressive government
intervention it should be illegal
to report on the pandemic and it's also
even funnier because to the extent any
of this is funny
it should be against election law trump
says the media
should be bound by election law in what
they can cover they're not even running
for anything election law typically
applies
to candidates to campaigns and to donors
textbook fascism this is a lunatic
wannabe dictator now news
about a hundred year pandemic should be
against the law trump says
biden should be in jail but he won't
tell us what crimes were committed
he says he will lock up the bidens trump
has been putting pressure on william
barr to investigate the bidens
trump won't commit to a peaceful
transfer of power
but i don't think it will work anyway in
the sense of
trying to suppress the fact that 230 000
realistically 310
000 if you actually look at excess
mortality
hundreds of thousands of people needless
to say have died on his watch
trying to suppress it i don't think will
make people forget about it
and i don't think it will make people
forgive donald trump not the same
rational people anyway
although there's plenty of outrageous
people around as well
but the most important thing to debunk
here is the idea that kovid
had to be bad for politicians it's been
horrible for the world as far as tragedy
and death
and suffering but politically it's only
bad if you mishandle it
new zealand's president was re-elected
in a landslide
because she successfully kept the
pandemic under control she also happens
to be a normal person who's not
completely out of touch with reality
so trump could be sailing to re-election
if he had handled this correctly serious
question to conservatives
do you support trump's statement that
it should be against the law for the
news to report on a pandemic because
there's an election close by
seems indefensible and yet i'm
continuously surprised by what the right
is willing to support
should the media be banned from
discussing kovid
close to an election the majority of
trumpists i'm seeing online now these
are just the ones willing to comment
online
there could be a vast silent majority
that is against this
but what i'm seeing online from trump is
is uh it was taken out of context
it uh trump only said it as a joke uh
the media should be banned from covering
it because they lie about it if they
told the truth they should be allowed to
cover it but because the fake news media
is lying about the pandemic they
shouldn't be allowed to cover it
i want to hear from trumpists do you
agree with this should it be illegal
to cover coronavirus i'm on twitter at d
pacman let me know the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that our program is mostly
funded by members who sign up at
joinpakman.com
who can be a member you can be a member
grab a membership at joinpackman.com uh
so there's been this trending story
that was really fueled by donald trump
that after last week's second and final
presidential debate
millions and millions of people started
googling how can i change my vote if
i've already sent in my vote
if i voted early can i change my vote
the idea being
people saw trump's powerful alpha
performance on thursday
and said oh no i voted for biden
but i must change my vote to trump can i
do it
unfortunately the backstory doesn't
actually match
reality a lot of those searches the vast
majority actually started
the day that the 60 minutes interview
aired sunday which was
not a good interview for donald trump
but trump seemed to think
that there was an explosion of voters
looking to change their votes from biden
to trump after voting
so donald trump tweeted quote strongly
trending
google since immediately after the
second debate
is can i change my vote this refers
changing it to me the answer
in most states is yes go do it
most important election of your life
now first of all i don't think this is
people looking to change their votes
already cast from biden to trump
um again the timing is not what trump
says it was not after the second debate
it was overwhelmingly the 60 minutes
interview that seems to have triggered
people to say can i change my vote now
you could you could venture a guess oh
it's people wanting to change from biden
to trump or vice versa
as more and more people vote early by
sheer
math you would imagine that more people
are going to be searching for that
without necessarily wanting to do it but
let's put that aside
it is not true that you simply
can change your vote there are some
states where you can
but overwhelmingly you cannot in florida
for example where donald trump now votes
if you cast your absentee ballot and
it's been received processed and counted
you can't change your vote
you just can't do it there are some
states like minnesota michigan wisconsin
new york
pennsylvania mississippi connecticut
they do allow
alteration of votes after early voting
that's six states so first of all trump
is against spreading
voting disinformation on twitter
secondly
and maybe most importantly it is not
clear
that this is people trying to change
their votes to trump
it started trending after trump's
ridiculous interview on 60 minutes
where he walked out after getting
reasonable
real questions and trump looked terrible
trump thinks it's in his favor
because the new york post published a
story suggesting
you know biden's laptop uh we you know
what whatever
um most voters didn't see that story
that story is not getting a lot of
attention because it's ridiculous and
has nothing to do with joe biden
so this is a very scared man who might
get reelected
he actually might get reelected whatever
the truth is
about people wanting to change votes
from biden to trump
from trump to biden yes trump is scared
yes trump is desperate
but unless we ensure he doesn't he could
get himself re-elected he's on the ropes
he's trying anything he can now he's on
vote changing after going from one topic
to another to another
the trumpists are pretending that this
is not
disturbing behavior but he is spreading
more voting disinformation on twitter
in uh the overwhelming number of states
you cannot change your vote
trump is acting like you can and the
really cynical but maybe maybe it's not
overly it's cynical but it's not overly
cynical maybe
there's this idea that the reason trump
is doing this
is he is just trying to create chaos
and tons of people who try to change
their votes
who maybe will come away on november 3rd
believing their vote counted for the
wrong person
because they tried but it wasn't clear
did they change it did they not
the cynic would look at this and say
this isn't just
trump wildly spreading desperate
disinformation on twitter
this is trump specifically crafting
stories
that voters will tell on november 3rd
to justify lawsuits to justify
courts getting involved sorry i hit my
microphone there
to justify any way possible
to steal the election from joe biden
that's what a cynic would say
but i don't know that it's overly
cynical given what we've seen
let's continue our discussion of the
desperation
from the trump campaign the president is
now so desperate
that he's holding three rallies per day
in the middle of a hundred year pandemic
yesterday holding rallies in allentown
pennsylvania
lititz pennsylvania that sounds weird
but i guess i
maybe it's lightits i'm not i hope i'm
not mispronouncing that
and martinsburg pennsylvania all three
of them in pennsylvania
that i can tell you with full
pronunciation certainty
i'm not going to go through all of these
rallies with you i'm going to go through
some elements
they are completely dystopian
authoritarian nightmares the likes of
which we actually have never seen before
in american history we've seen stuff
like this in other parts of the world
particularly
in the 20th century but we've not seen
this type of stuff in america
i'm going to go through just a few
highlights to give you an overall sense
of how much of an emergency it is to
remove this man
starting in allentown pennsylvania
yesterday morning donald trump
who has continued to say foreign leaders
want biden to win
because trump is so tough on them now
trump is just making up conversations
claiming a foreign leader said joe biden
would sleep all the time if he were
president take a listen to this
police are elected they will delay the
vaccine delay therapies prolong the
pandemic
close your schools your schools have to
open and shut down our country
that doesn't have a clue this guy
doesn't have a clue have you seen what
this
i mean he we can't play with the country
the only thing i can tell you for sure
president xi from china president putin
from russia
kim jong-un north korea and i could name
40 others
their sharpest attack
they don't want to deal with sleepy jail
one of them said to me one of the
leaders said well i hope you win because
we don't want to deal with somebody that
sleeps
all the time do you believe that no he
just announced the lid
well no you know now now that you
mention it i don't believe that that
conversation happened i don't think it
did
this is really interesting trump did the
thing yesterday
he used to do this back in 2016. he
pulled out a piece of paper out of his
jacket pocket
where he reads polling numbers and trump
is trying to push back on polls that
show him losing the election
but he's doing it by bragging about his
leads
in places like utah and west virginia
i'll tell you why this is interesting in
a moment
in montana we're so far up they don't
even they shouldn't even have the
election
likewise in utah so far up
we're plus 12 plus 15.
[Applause]
and in west virginia with 20 up 20
points up
these are just came out they came out
today if you are a republican
incumbent president and you're bragging
about polling in utah and west virginia
you are in trouble you are in trouble if
in order to have
good numbers you are even mentioning
utah and virginia two states that
because they are so red
are irrelevant to the electoral college
process in practice they're not
irrelevant
they're irrelevant because their results
are not in question the election doesn't
hinge on them and trump is saying
i'm doing great in utah i'm doing great
in west virginia
very troubling sign trump continuing his
complete rage against wind power he
seems to believe that
if there's wind power if it's not windy
out you can't watch tv
no air conditioning in the summer no
heat during the winter
and no electricity during peak hours
let's watch
president trump on television i'm sorry
we won't be able to do it
the wind isn't blowing today darling
and part of the tragedy is that the
crowd
seems to also think that's how wind
power works if it isn't windy you can't
watch tv
if it's not windy you can't toast your
bread in that moment
complete misunderstanding deliberate
ignorance we may never know then trump
moving on from allentown pennsylvania to
letits pennsylvania trump struggling to
say
extremist i guess this is extremist and
trump
just struggling to speak by rally number
two
i'm keeping the terrorist jihadist and
violent extremists
those terrible extremists the hell out
of our country if that's okay
trump fans then starting a lock him up
chant towards hunter biden lock up
hillary
lock up joe biden lock up the biden's
lock up hunter biden
the state is supposed to ask us and they
weren't going to
but we told them i'm sorry where's
hunter where is hunter he's making
he's he's trying to make a deal with a
foreign country to pay him 10 million
where's hunter remember the t-shirt
where's hunter i was right
thank you very much for that squares
this can only happen in pennsylvania
right
i was here for school
[Applause]
the party claiming to be for the
constitution
for law and order for due process
regularly demanding the imprisonment
without due process
of random people who haven't even been
accused of crimes
law and order right constitutional
conservatives
trump then going back to the vaccine
saying any sec
momentarily we're going to have it he
might maybe he'll even announce it at a
rally today
ends the pandemic which is ending with
or without and we have the vaccines
they're going to be very
nobody would have them it would be years
before you had them what i did with fda
and fda has been terrific but it was
called a slightly speedier process okay
and totally safe we will have the
vaccine like
momentarily and we're all set to
distribute it before the end of
the year maybe substantially before but
it's going good
but we are going to get ourselves back
to normal life i said normal life
where we were seven months ago so as we
have heard
from trump many times we were expecting
a vaccine approval
early october mid-october late october
before the election we were expecting
people
according to trump to start getting the
vaccine before the election
not happening not happening and uh by
any reasonable
sense from our actual public health
experts
if we are lucky if things go i don't
want to say luck but if things go
perfectly
we hopefully will have some people
starting to get vaccinated by the end of
this year
then on from latits pennsylvania to
martinsburg pennsylvania trump
criticizing barack obama
for having a small crowd today obama
didn't do any event
today which was yesterday doesn't matter
it's all fiction here it's really
something right did you see the crowd
that president obama had today
nobody nobody showed up i thought they'd
have a little crowd didn't quite have a
crowd like this
no nobody showed up they said he's going
to start campaigning i said who
barack hussein obama i said oh i said is
that good or bad because you know he
campaigned harder than hillary the last
time how did that work out it didn't
work
out and then while bashing joe biden
this is funny trump gets confused
and says biden is going to give you the
biggest tax cut in the history of the
country
just like maybe a moment of clarity
or just trump confused about what he
wants to say the largest tax cut in
history this is the craziest campaign
right so all my life i watch politicians
running they always say
we are going to cut your taxes right
we are going to cut your i got a guy
running now
who sort of shot he goes we
will raise your taxes i said what the
hell
i said did he just say that yeah he's
going to give you the biggest tax cut
in the history of our country yeah i got
confused watching it live
but biden's plan i mean the funny thing
is
biden's plan actually is a tax cut for
the bottom 95 percent of americans
and a tax hike for the top five percent
of income earners
uh unclear what trump meant to say is
trump confused that he accidentally tell
the truth
you never know with this guy and then
donald trump again
incoherent on mexico paying for the wall
which they did but don't have to do
because it's built
but they paid for it who knows what the
hell he's talking about
and mexico is paying for the wall by the
way in case you had any question that's
the other thing
so now they know it's built then they
said but mexico will not be paying for i
said no no mexico is paying for the wall
okay but
they'll figure that out very soon
they'll confiscate
again a total lie the truth is there is
no wall i think they've added about 10
miles
as part of a wall repair program there
is no wall
trump promised the wall across the
entire border by the end of his first
term
there's no wall there okay and mexico
has paid for nothing
there's no toll on people coming into
the united states from
none of it is true and then just as they
sort of
mildly xenophobic uh icing on the cake
trump now regularly at rallies referring
to the former president as barack
hussein obama this is a common trope
hussein hussein hussein hussain
sounds like an arab right this is the
idea of trump repeating it
[Applause]
and part of that was that barack hussein
obama
allowed me to have 142. that's become a
new staple of these rallies in the last
couple of weeks
authoritarian nightmare three more
rallies today
we may cover some of them live barack
obama will also be rallying for joe
biden this week and i plan to cover
those
and we will have more coverage of this
authoritarian nightmare
on the show's instagram page if you are
on instagram
follow the show at david pakman show and
follow me
at david.pacman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking to
william irvine who's a professor of
philosophy at wright state university
and author of many books including the
one i most recently read
a guide to the good life the ancient art
of stoic
joy uh so uh great to have you on i
really appreciate your time
oh my pleasure to be here so i think um
i think that this
stoicism is a particularly relevant
topic right now
for all those following american
politics
and thinking about the the next few
weeks but before we
we so obviously link these ideas to
what's going on
maybe we can speak a little generally
about the ideas of stoicism and and some
of the
most notable purveyors of these ideas
that you write about including seneca
and marcus aurelius and and others maybe
first you can
disabuse some of our audience
about what stoicism is not which is
maybe
an indifference to what is going on in
the world an indifference to tragedy and
indifference to the struggles of life
that's not what it is as you write about
in the book what's the right
thought process for thinking about
stoicism
yeah the strange thing is the stoics
turn out to have been cheerful
uh individuals and you wouldn't think
that
so i like to distinguish between lower
case s stoics and these
are people who are simply gloomy
and glum and they just their idea of
what you do in life is you just stand
there and withstand whatever life throws
at you
and that's not the stoics uppercase s
stoics at all
and these were individuals you mentioned
some of the names people like seneca
people like
like epictetus people like marcus
aurelius
who uh realized life is tough
and so you have to have a strategy for
dealing
with a life that you know is going to be
tough and there
they were not anti-emotion they were
anti-negative emotions and they thought
quite sensibly that what you should do
in your life is you should try to
minimize the number of negative emotions
you experience and these are emotions
like
anger anxiety envy and grief
but they had absolutely nothing against
positive emotions and in fact they
thought
we should be embracing positive emotions
uh positive emotions are different than
pleasures okay
so it's an important distinction but
positive emotions like feelings of
delight and even
feelings of joy that's what we should be
in pursuit of
and and these guys were the um
preeminent psychologists of their time
and they hit upon some psychological
strategies that work
uh wonderfully well and so what i've
done in my books is i've tried to share
those strategies
with a a broader public so
i think that this will a lot of this
is just the timing of this conversation
is is beautifully
timed because i think many of the things
you talk about in the book including
negative visualization and understanding
the dichotomy or really the trichotomy
of control
these things are so relevant for anybody
who is
worried about the election results that
that we
are waiting for can you talk a little
bit about
maybe to start with the idea of negative
visualization and
it's sort of relevance to day-to-day
life
yeah negative visualization is a simple
technique
and what you do is you pause in your
daily business
it only takes a few seconds to do and
you think about something that's
important to you something that plays a
very significant role in your life and
it could be your job
it could be your spouse or your
significant other
it could be your children and now
take a moment to imagine that that thing
disappeared from your uh life and there
are lots of ways
that can happen you know people many
people have recently lost a job
uh or split up with their significant
others imagine that happening and now
the point is you don't dwell on that
because that would be a recipe for a
miserable existence
what you do instead is you allow
yourself to have a few seconds in which
you really
think about that then go on with your
daily business and it's it's almost
a magical effect because next time you
encounter
the person that you imagined uh losing
or you imagine being separated from
it'll be a different experience because
you will no longer be taking that person
for granted
and that's the problem with human
existence you know whatever we're
whatever we we have and work so hard to
get once we've got it
we take it for granted and we think oh
well this is fine but you know if only i
had some more
you know a different uh significant
other
a different job i would finally be happy
so
we put ourselves on this treadmill and
and what a sad way to spend the one life
that you have to live
yes sometimes the the concept of hedonic
adaptation is used for
this sort of way in which we as humans
very quickly establish the status quo
as a new baseline even if it's better
for example or it could be worse but
even if it's better than
99 of our prior existence on the planet
it very quickly becomes the new baseline
from which our existence is sort of
judged
am i wrong to think that the idea of
negative visualization may be a sort of
antidote to that adaptation that takes
place
yeah it's it's like it's like an
ointment you know when you start taking
your life for
uh for granted uh it's anointment that
you can apply
as needed and uh and it is uh
interesting you know stoics and they
aren't alone doing this but a lot of the
philosophies of the ancient world
advised you to not only be a spectator
of the lives
of other people which is what we kind of
instinctively do
but be a spectator of your own life
watch
yourself watch what motivates you watch
the way you react to the events of the
day
and then really think about what you're
doing because
uh you know you can look around you and
you can see people
who work so hard to get something and
they finally get it
and they're really really happy for an
hour
or a day or maybe a week and then the
new
wears off and they're right back where
they were before
you know it's it's like a a poor a poor
a poor guy
chasing mirages across the desert you
know off
there in the distance there's water and
if only i can crawl to it i will at last
have water to drink gets there and it
evaporates it's gone
right and then just has to do that again
you've got like i say one life to live
and you know what we do is we look
around and we see how other people are
living their lives
and we assume somebody has done their
homework somebody somewhere has figured
this out
so i'll just copy them but throughout
the millennia
there have been people who have stood
back and looked at this and said you
know
nobody's done their homework and by re
by doing what
what other people are doing in this case
you're only going to get yourself in
trouble
at some kind of superficial level that
this might sound very anti sort of
consumerist the idea that
there's no product one can buy that is
going to sort of give them
whatever degree of happiness they might
imagine they would achieve
by by buying a certain product but when
i read the book
i got more of the impression that um
it's
it's not necessarily that but it's more
about
making decisions consciously and
thoughtfully
and and not just writing off
where we get and and maintaining that
appreciation can you comment about that
a little bit i mean this is that doesn't
sound
necessarily like an anti-capitalist or
anti-consumer culture ideology but it's
more about recognizing
and understanding how we are sort of
wired in a sense
to uh very quickly adjust to whatever it
is that we have
yeah uh you know if you if you believe
in evolution
i and i do our ancestors back in africa
who were perfectly happy with what they
had
they didn't survive uh they didn't
spread their their genes the ones that
survived
were the ones that were constantly
thinking about things that had happened
trying to learn from them so they didn't
make the mistakes over
trying to think about what was going to
happen you know this idea this
this dream of living in the present
moment our
ancestors on the savannahs of africa who
did that
got eaten by a lion you know and that
was the that was the end of
uh of their story so um
there is this thing that i refer to as
the gap theory of happiness and that is
that there's a gap
between what you have and what you want
and then so one way to close that gap
and gain happiness
is by working hard to get the thing that
you want but there's another way
and that is you reverse the gap the
other way you learn to want the things
you
already have because uh and there there
will be a lot of people who
who reject this claim on the face of it
you have
so much in your life and whatever it is
you think you absolutely
need to have look at your life and look
at how your
ancestors would have looked at your life
they would have regarded you as dreaming
as living in a dream world you have all
of this stuff
what you have a device in your pocket
that can not only talk to somebody in
china but you can see them talking while
you do it that's just
crazy and yet here people have it
and people now you know when they don't
have the latest model cell phone they
feel
ah well you know my life is is is ruined
so take what you already have learn to
appreciate it learn to be thankful
for the existence you find yourself
living learn to
embrace your life and
um now if you look back at the uh at the
stoics
they didn't simply go into dormant mode
where they said okay i'm fine with that
they
they turned out to be some very uh
productive and ambitious
people um seneca for instance
besides being a philosopher was an
advisor to an emperor
was the first century
a.d equivalent of a billionaire and was
one of the greatest playwrights of his
time so he was
no slouch but you know the idea of
waking up in the morning and just
feeling
wonderful that you get to be having the
life that you're having
and a large part of that is your own
attitude and your own attitude
can be is very much in your control so
let that's a perfect segue so
the um one of the things that uh
i see with my audience that is causing
significant anxiety
as we get closer to this election and my
audience being a left-leaning audience
is overwhelmingly folks who want to
uh see donald trump go is
have i done enough i have anxiety about
the results
and if we introduce the idea of a
dichotomy of control where we would
separate
things into that which we can control
and that which we cannot control it sort
of falls
short when it comes to something like an
election which is where
the idea of the trichotomy of control is
is so useful
those things over which we have some
control and i think in the book you talk
about a tennis match where ultimately
you don't really have unilateral control
of the results but
certainly you can have control over your
practice plan you can have control over
your attitude and expectations going
into the match
etc and for me that's been a perfect
analogy to the election where
well we're all voters and as voters we
do have some control and we control
our one vote we also can decide whether
to
phone bank or not and if so in which
states but ultimately
with 130 or 135 million expected votes
no one of us can control the results so
can you can you give us a sense of a
healthy way
to sort of apply this to something like
a national
election with a not infinite but
very large number of moving parts many
of which over we don't have control
yeah this is the most complicated
election of my lifetime
so much going on so much
unpredictability
and i'm ready to be surprised that's my
plan going into it
and you know the last uh election in uh
2016
uh i'm an extreme early riser and i was
up at about two in the morning and i
turned on the tv
expecting to see hillary's face there
beaming
and it was donald trump instead and i
thought whoa
so i'm ready for for absolutely anything
the dichotomy of control there are
things you can control in things you
can't
and if you spend your time worrying
about things you can't control you're
going to be a very anxious and unhappy
individual
so think about things you can control
and do those to the best of your ability
so in the case of a tennis match you can
control how hard you train
you can control whether you party the
night before or whether you try to get a
good night's sleep
you can control your strategy can you
control how hard the other person
practices and no you can't so that does
that isn't even part of your equation
and by the way we come into the notion
here of success
in failures so for a stoic what counts
is success
success is to put it into a a motto
success is doing what you could with
what you
had where you were if you did those
things
you have succeeded because what else
could you do
right you you did what you you could
and with the election stoics would have
a two-stage plan number one
is don't worry about things you have no
control over
and number two is be emotionally
prepared
for surprises so the stoics were
were big on what i call stoic training
where you go out of your way
to do things that are difficult just
because they're hard to do
do things where there's a significant
chance of failure not catastrophic
failure but failure in some sense of the
word
how come just so you can get used to
failing you know successful people are
typically people who have experienced a
lot of failure
what makes them special is when they
failed they didn't break
they bounced they took the failure they
learned from the failure
they went on to do new better failures
than they had before and finally popped
out
at the end of the tunnel what's
conventionally called a successful
person
so with this prepare yourself for
just about anything emotionally and just
say don't know where it's going
but wherever it goes what i will do is i
will do
what i can with what i've got where i am
we will pause our conversation with
professor of philosophy william irvine
there the full conversation will be
available on our youtube channel
youtube.com
slash the david pakman show very soon we
will go to a quick break on the podcast
radio pro program and tv show and be
back very very soon the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
i've told you guys before that jared
kushner donald trump's son-in-law
is truly a sinister force in american
politics and in the world
and jared's back you know after he did
that one
coronavirus press briefing where he said
things like
you know the stockpile is our stockpile
it's not
a stockpile for the states they pulled
him out
of public view because he's been a
disaster now he's back
jared kushner reappearing on fox news
yesterday he was asked about
the black american community and he
brought us a beautiful message of hope
and unity which was hey listen
trump's policies have been the right
policies but
we can't make black people more success
successful than they want to be we can
only help them so much
we can't make them want to be successful
if they don't want to be successful i
guess that this was
how jared kushner thought he was
defending trump's policy
towards black americans and other
minority groups i don't know but take a
look at this embarrassing fiasco
i think we've seen in a lot of the the
the black community which is mostly
democrat is that
president trump's policies are the
policies that can help people break out
of the problems that they're complaining
about
but he can't want them to be successful
more than they want to be successful and
what you're seeing throughout the
country now
is a groundswell support in the black
community because they're realizing that
all the different bad things that the
media and the democrats have said about
president trump
are not true and so they're seeing that
he's actually delivered he's put up
results and a lot of people want to get
on board to start working with president
trump because they know that
you know unlike most politicians who
have been in washington for decades who
talk and say all the right things
president trump may not always say the
right things but he does the right
things
is this the right message days before
the election like maybe the calculation
is
by saying this eight days before an
election as he did yesterday
he'll bring in more of the racist vote
than the number of of other folks that
will leave
because of the the message i don't know
and of course
jared kushner's personal lack of
self-awareness
about wanting to be successful being
what matters
he was born with a silver spoon in his
mouth
had businesses handed to him by his dad
his dad essentially
paid his way into harvard it is you know
the
height of lack of self-awareness and
hypocrisy it's just another instance
really
of the same projection we've been seeing
for years
with this family major transition into
the second term
it's not our fault they're just not
working hard enough we can only help
them succeed so much
the guy was born on third base and he's
telling
actual batters how to hit a triple
that's the best analogy i can think of
for this
and honestly when people say this stuff
out loud
how does he walk around without getting
punched in the face is it just 24 7
security that keeps the guy from getting
slapped
and by the way this idea of a
groundswell of support for donald trump
from the black community
it's also a farce the latest ibd
poll has trump polling eight percent
with black voters another poll has trump
polling
seven percent with black voters there is
no ground swell
of black support for donald trump now
many republicans will say oh david
the reason black voters aren't
supporting trump
is they've been tricked by the
democratic party into
essentially signing a blank check for
them and voting for democrats no matter
what
which is really a way of saying black
people aren't
actually evaluating candidates they've
been tricked
which i guess means they're not that
smart they've been tricked
into voting for the democratic party now
the truth is
black folks and hispanic folks and women
and the college educated and on and on
all these groups that are supporting joe
biden they're doing it because they know
what trump offers and they don't want it
that's really the reason black voters
and others
aren't supporting trump but back to
jared kushner and the idea that trump
can only help help black people so much
they have to help themselves
is this just a play for the racist vote
have they calculated
let's bring in more racist whites
we'll lose some black voters if jared
says this but will bring in more racist
whites who are overwhelmingly
there's more racist whites than black
people watching fox news uh in the
morning let's put
let's be let's be clear is it a
calculation or am i reading too much
into it there's no calculation it's just
jared being jared and that's it
as if you needed another reason to
remove trump
we might be only a week out from never
having to hear from
jared kushner again which for me is a
really great incentive to vote to remove
donald trump which i've already done
this really is a reminder that the right
has no
policy on broad-based economic stimulus
for the lower and middle class
regardless of race we can say
the left's policy isn't good enough we
can say the democratic party
isn't left enough on economic policy
but at least the left thinks you need
policy jared and republicans have this
idea
you can't help people if they won't help
themselves if they won't pull themselves
up by their own bootstraps to
revitalize a completely ridiculous idea
why can't poor people
just decide to stop being poor jared
kushner's frustrated
that poor people keep deciding to be
poor
that's what this comes down to it's a
malignancy and we've got to remove it
speaking by the way of malignancies
this is just hilarious we've talked for
years
about the debt and deficit being a
political football
both democrats and republicans throw the
football back and forth to some degree
republicans do it more
and republicans claim to be about low
deficits cutting the debt
when a democratic president is in the
white house but
when all of a sudden a republican
president
is in they don't talk about it george w
bush
exploding the debt donald trump
exploding the debt you get a democrat in
the white house all of a sudden oh
infrastructure
coveted stimulus if biden wins you you
know you will hear it
uh how are we gonna afford that well
deranged and depraved republican
senator ted cruz is taking it a step
further
instead of saying the debt doesn't
matter he's instead
saying trump never ran on reducing the
deficit or the debt now of course trump
not only ran
on it trump hilariously promised to
completely eliminate the national debt
by running huge surpluses during his
first term
he's done the opposite he's run record
deficits you have to see the video to
believe it
listen to the audio here is ted cruz
trying to
pull this on jonathan swann from a
forthcoming interview on axios on hbo
jonathan swann instantly fact-checking
him and
uh ted cruz just has to come up with
some other lie he said you know the
deficit's the worst thing in the world
when barack obama's president but
donald trump came in and you know we're
not so worried about that anymore
he's right isn't he so look i'm very
worried about the debt
and i'm worried about it under trump
uh now to be fair trump didn't campaign
on cutting the debt
he did he said he's going to eliminate
the national debt in eight years
he also said something what is it i'm
the king of debt
uh in 2016. right so we actually have to
look into this in detail because this
is not merely ted cruz being a buffoon
it is ted cruz being a buffoon but this
is part of a bigger
sort of transition that many republicans
are making
in case joe biden were to win what many
republicans are doing
is starting to pretend to care about the
deficit again so that if joe biden wins
and does a coronavirus stimulus they can
go back to
we can't afford this the debt the debt
the debt
now of course trump did run on paying
off the national debt
he said repeatedly that his tax plan was
going to be so good
and create so much growth that we'd run
a surplus and pay off the debt within
four or five years of him becoming
president
here's trump telling hannity he could do
it in five years or maybe even in less
time
we can balance the budget very quickly
but do you think in five years
i think over a five-year period and i
don't know maybe i could even surprise
you
there's a ton of these clips i won't
bore you with them but
then ted cruz when he's called out says
well
you know trump did also say he's the
king of debt
this is idiocy this is idiocy when trump
said
he's the king of debt he wasn't bragging
about
i will increase the deficit i'm the king
of debt as far as
growing the national debt is concerned
what trump was saying was
i'm the king of debt i know how to
renegotiate the debt
i know how to reduce it or restructure
it which he also
hasn't done as president how pathetic is
ted cruz
as far as the facts go to just get them
in here
we are putting a chart up for our video
audience of the total federal public
debt over time
which as you can see even aside from the
massive spike
at the time of coronavirus the debt was
trending up faster
during donald trump than during barack
obama's presidency
and everything ted cruz says about it
makes no sense so this is the same
tired game that's been played for
decades democrat comes in
slows down deficit growth sometimes like
bill clinton even generates a surplus
then republicans come in and do
something insane to blow it up like
george w
bush invading a country that didn't even
attack us democrat comes back in barack
obama
slows down deficit growth every time he
wants to spend republicans say how are
we going to pay for it
trump runs on eliminating the debt
blows it up and in comes ted cruz saying
well
trump never really ran on it so yes both
sides play the debt deficit games
but republicans are the ones actually
increasing the deficit like no other
and ted cruz really needs to go as a
reminder now sadly
he's not on the ballot right now he just
won re-election in 2018
he'll be back on the ballot in 2024 his
time will come
we can hope we can hope we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p got a very interesting voicemail
about the supreme court and the upcoming
election
hi david this is john hixson member in
good standing from hybridge
by the way i love member in good
standing
you could be a member in bad standing i
like that we have a clarification here
member in good standing
here's what i predict happens on
election night since
trump has you know inspired all of his
voters to vote on election day right
walk in
on election night he wins in the walk-in
voting count
yes and then the next day he has the
supreme court
suspend the count of all the mail-in
ballots because it will be injurious to
his re-election
campaign and they will cite bush regor
as precedent that's interesting the idea
of citing bush vigorous president for
hijinks at the court
i i've not actually heard that
specifically before but
certainly this is the general fear that
the supreme court now with the six to
three majority
thanks to last night's swearing-in of
amy coney barrett
uh will be used to stop
the counting of mail-in ballots
particularly in key
states pennsylvania's the one that comes
to mind because they don't even start
counting mail-in ballots
until the polls close on election day uh
that this is exactly the nightmare
scenario we've been
talking about for sure and uh is joe
biden
ready with lawyers to prevent it i don't
know eric garcetti told me he is
uh i don't know we will talk today on
the bonus show
about the idea of expanding the court
and what is implicit there a water on
the moon
nasa's sophia uh uh
craft has discovered water on the moon
and kazakhstan now likes
the latest borat movie very very
interesting stuff on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video